let's start with a question from
jason moore otherwise known as at
laneman24 is it more likely that the
lack of draft prep hurts incompetent
organizations more or gives a bigger leg
up to the well-run teams chris what do
you think well it's a good this is a
good question very good question i
actually think it hurts the well-run
teams i do i think the well-run teams
have this process down
to a science to where yes between the
evaluation of film personal workouts and
meeting with a guy
they know what they really like and i
think the the aspect of the personal
workout
is where i think it's going to really
hurt the well-run teams though the
well-run teams are able to go oh i saw
something on film i like all right you
know i'm not so sure about the
competition around them and all those
things man you know i also like these
other guys at this position too let's
get them in here for a personal workout
and then we can get a little closer look
and i think the really well-run teams
have an eye
for you know certain positions or
certain players or just knowing what to
look for in a workout to go
that's going to translate to the nfl
right i always think of dante scarneckia
here mike with this dante scarnecchia
had like his own routine in new england
that he put the offensive lineman
through
when it was a free agent or a draft guy
which was not the same as any other
offensive line coach i ever saw put
through a routine and it was certain
stretch flexibility drills other
strength drills all these type of things
that allow dante scarneckia to nitpick a
guy and go oh i like that he can do this
and he can do that and he can't do this
and then scarneckia could find that
diamond in the rough or whoever it may
be or distinguish who was better and not
better and you're going to lose that
aspect if you have that guy that with a
keen eye in your organization right now
and remember they did have scarneckia go
with them to the scouting combine so the
patriots got a little bit of that but
not the extent that they're used to and
i agree with you look even though the
good teams the best teams will come up
with creative ways to thrive or survive
in this environment for the teams that
were dysfunctional anyway who cares
we're throwing a dart as it is right
we're taking the guys who slide down the
board because we don't know who they
allow us to take anyway so i i agree
with you the more you take away the
opportunity for teams
to get maximum information the teams
that know how to gather it and make the
most of it are going to have less
information less valuable information
than they usually have whereas the teams
that that don't know what the hell
they're doing
who cares if you don't have the ability
to go do all these things they're not
spending the money and the time and then
all the expertise to do it right anyway
well yeah exactly you know and even
another aspect of it is you know hey
let's let's take for example like pete
carroll and john schneider i look at
those two guys and go man they have
unbelievable people skills they know how
to work you know guys who maybe had a
little bit of a checkered past or not
the best like history on the personal
side and they can work them into the
organization it just seems like it works
good you know they have an unbelievable
skill set of communication and and
people skills to where that's going to
get lost in this process too i know you
can do the zoom and facetime calls
but you know
do the seattle seahawks take dk metcalf
last year with there's some of the bad
rumors that were going around on him
you know without the fact that they got
to meet him and be around him and really
get to know him and spend a day i'm just
giving examples of like that where yeah
i know zoom zoom is good but you're not
really getting to spend the day eat
dinner really get into some different
topics everything like that see the body
language of a guy see if he's moody or
not anything like that you know the
teams that have really good people
skills i think they're hurting this
whole conversation too
yeah you know i agree with you my first
thought was the the good teams are still
going to do a great job in the draft but
i think it is a greater challenge for
them because what made them great at
drafting was taking full advantage of
all the things that you can
do
to prepare to gather information to work
directly with players etc
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports